just when I thought the summer movie
season was done and over the apes get
smart and they rise Rise of the Planet
of the Apes
so Rise of the Planet of the Apes is the
story of how the Apes rose like how the
Planet of the Apes came to be and you
see the gist of it in the trailer James
Franco and company are coming up with a
serum that cures Alzheimer's and one of
the apes has all the effects of that
serum so James Franco takes a little
baby ape home names him Caesar you know
behind the company's back you can't have
known about that yeah he'd get fired and
then he raises them and because of the
serum Caesar is super smart and it'll
probably end badly for you know humanity
now for me there were a couple concerns
in this movie first of all I didn't
think I'd buy James Franco as a doctor
any I know I've heard I'm actually
Jeremy James Franco is going for his
ph.d yeah I know and if I were a chide
have a PhD too but the funny thing about
this movie is I thought James Franco was
gonna be the main character you know
we'd see Caesar grow up but you know to
concentrate on Franco what it doesn't
like at all James Franco's the
supporting character the main character
in this movie is actually Caesar yep the
CGI age I didn't expect that and it
really works for this movie and the
other thing I was worried about is was
the movie gonna illustrate that the ape
was really smart or is he just like you
know and a Fed they tell you is smart
but yeah you can tell Caesar is not like
other apes at a point in the movie you
see this in the trailer Caesar gets
taken away from James Franco and he's
among all these other apes and you can
tell he is smarter than them they act
like animals he actually acts like a
person kind of and when James Franco
interacts with them he interacts with
him like a friend so you feel that kind
of connection and when Caesar is in this
like community ape holding place he gets
treated like by Draco Malfoy and he
gets really jaded in there with anyone
would and I also really like that that's
when the movie became badass for me I
mean I thought the whole Caesar thing
was really cool it was like all right
yeah genetics and you know brain and
he's really smart and I like that but at
a point in this facility you see Caesar
something behind his eyes just snaps and
he's just like yep things are different
now and then he takes action Caesar is
one of the coolest characters in a movie
like this year yeah the CGI ape is one
of the coolest characters in a movie
this year believe it he is an absolute
badass he is like the John Connor for
Apes and you're on his side too like at
a point when he's all like
you're like you know what you go for it
buddy you've earned it you deserve it
this movie had some sweet moments too
like when the Apes are storming the
place that was cool but there's one part
in the movie I'm not gonna tell you what
it was but I didn't expect it and it
happened and I was just like holy
that just got real it's an intriguing
science movie mixed with like a
rebellion freedom fighter movie sick
thing is that was on the ape side I was
like dude Caesar lead him to freedom
which might make me an because
it's pretty much like saying dude Caesar
screw the human race and I'm humans it's
weird the only thing is that you know
like you're like how our Apes gonna take
out human beings we have Gatling guns
and we'll Gatling guns but it's not
really like that it's the start of the
whole thing so for what they end up
doing in the movie you buy it
you're not like no dude that couldn't
happen so I was really teetering on the
edge I didn't know what I was gonna rate
the movie is it buy it on blu-ray is an
awesome tacular but i gotta say it's a
really interesting movie for the first
half it's a really cool and exciting
movie for the second half and it
involves one of the greatest lead
performances of the year this cgi ape
Caesar every time I say it it sounds
strange to me but it just is so I gotta
say the movie is awesome tacular rise
that the Planet of the Apes is what a
reboot should be or a prequel whichever
one you think it's a reboot but you know
there's gonna be people who are gonna be
like actually it's a pretty cool
spider-man's getting a rebate dude it's
a reboot so I hope they make a sequel to
this movie a sequel can go one of two
ways and I want to see which way they go
so Rise of the Planet of the Apes are
you gonna see it have you seen it if
you've seen it you want to talk about it
so comment below talk about it let me
know what did you think and if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]